Okay.
You might remember that Donald Trump, uh,
once had this letter that Kim Jong Un sent
him, I think he might've called it a beautiful
letter or something like that.
Donald Trump had reporters in the room at
that time and he may have asked to go off
the record in terms of the contents or maybe
not.
And he held up the letter.
And from what we have learned so far, a reporter
from Time magazine held up his camera to take
a picture and Donald Trump said, and it's
sort of confusing and muddled and erratic,
like a lot of what Donald Trump says.
But what Trump said according to the transcript
is, uh, excuse me, under section two.
Well, you can go to prison instead because
if you use, if you use the photograph you
took of the letter that I gave you and time
tries to continue talking about the topic
of the interview, do you believe that people
should be and Trump interims interrupts confidentially.
I didn't give it to you to take photographs
of it, so don't play that game with me.
Let me just tell you something.
You take a look.
Time says, I'm sorry Mr President, were you
threatening me with prison time?
And Trump says, well, I told you the following,
I told you you can look at this off the record.
That doesn't mean you take out your camera
and start taking pictures of it.
Okay?
So I hope you don't have a picture of it.
I know you were very quick to pull it out
even you were surprised to see that you can't
do that stuff.
So go have fun with your story because I'm
sure it will be the 28th horrible story I
have in Time magazine because I never, I mean,
it's incredible.
With all I've done and the success I've had,
the way that Time magazine writes is absolutely
incredible.
Fascinatingly, this riled him up so much that
he then went into a huge rant about no collusion,
no obstruction as a result of a photographer
taking a picture.
It is just so incredible to read a transcript
of Donald Trump's scolding or report or for
taking a picture of something that Trump gave
confidentially, which he doesn't even understand
the meaning of while he has given up secrets
from allies to Russians in the Oval Office.
I mean, it's a jarring juxtaposition of what
Trump says and what Trump does.
And it's really important to understand here
when Trump says he gave something confidentially.
Confidential is a classification of documents.
You can't just yell out this is confidential
or you know, this pen is top secret and make
it so, and it's also really important to understand
that it's Trump who shouldn't be showing things
to people who don't have the correct clearances.
And more importantly, Trump and his aides
remember, have bragged endlessly about how
Trump can declassify anything he wants by
showing it to whoever he wants.
If Trump shows someone the picture, then he
has decided that it's okay for them to see
it.
It's also really funny that Trump mentioned
section two and then he seemed to realize
he didn't know what he was talking about.
Let's put the transcript back up on the screen
for a moment.
Trump started to say, excuse me, under section
two.
And then he kind of went away from that and
said, well, you can go to prison instead.
I guess he means article two of the constitution
or maybe section two of article two during
the same confused interview.
He seemed to be using the term section two
an article to uh, kind of interchangeably.
Like maybe they're the same thing and he doesn't
know what he's talking about.
Article two has two sections of the constitution.
Section one establishes basically how the
president and vice president are to be elected
and served four year terms.
Section two of article two talks about the
president being the head of the executive
branch of government and the commander in
chief of the armed forces who on earth knows
what Donald Trump was talking about when he
mentioned section two and then article too,
but at least at some point he seemed to have
the presence of mind to realize he doesn't
actually know what the hell he's talking about.
This is Trump though.
Okay.
When he was in private business, he would
threaten to sue anyone in business that he
didn't like.
That was his strategy and based on what we
know from Michael Cohen is former personal
attorney, that was a pretty effective strategy.
Sicking Michael Cohen, the attack dog on people
with threats of lawsuits was a pretty effective
way to get compliance from the people he wanted
to get compliance from.
Now he's threatening people with prison because
he's president of the United States.
It is truly chilling to see him wave prison
time around to reporters in this way.
And I know that there will be Trumpess who
see this and say, David, it was a vague threat.
He's generally talking about prison.
Freedom of the press is one of the most important,
uh, uh, speech freedoms that we have in this
country.
And a president threatening or even mentioning
prison to a reporter in this way is unheard
of except in extremely authoritarian dictatorial
circles.
And that is exactly what Donald Trump aspires
to.
And that's why this is so chilling in dangerous.
Let me know what you think.
Makes sure you're following me on Instagram
at [inaudible]
dot.
Pacman.
Make sure while you're there, you follow the
show on Instagram at David Pakman.
Show
the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com